hey gang welcome to the ru garbage
comedy podcast
please make sure you subscribe that way
you get the episodes as they come out
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast
this is are you garbage it's a show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find if they grow up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host holy coming at you on a beautiful
day we're down here
aunt toddy's basement she just made a
wawa run and i know she's on her way
back
because i just got a venmo request for
225 for a pack of crimpeds oh boy
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me that's all we had on that one
this week
light news and teddy huh okay he is the
ceo of ru garbage you put the whole
thing together he's the mastermind
ladies and gentlemen
give it up for kevin james ryan hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate if you subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are
true to [ __ ] roof and then
patreon.com you can sign up
you can get bonus episodes ayg you can
get episodes of hard feelings which is
just me and foley [ __ ] shooting the
[ __ ] him calling me bald me calling him
fat it's a good [ __ ] time oh yeah the
breakaway hit at 2021 by the way
everybody loves it
and then we'll play uh with our top tier
patrons we play ayg with you guys once
or twice a month you ask us questions we
ask you questions and then
and even bigger news oh tell them tell
them we're hitting the road jack [ __ ]
road april 20th
raleigh good nights down here in north
carolina april 21st zany's nashville
get your [ __ ] tickets now it's gonna
sell out
i'm telling you yeah guys chicago we
just got where chicago's almost sold out
so chicago's in june get those tickets
now uh
also indy is moving as well all the
tickets are moving baby the boys are
hitting the road check it out
we got the link tree up links in the
description check it out there we go and
of course speaking of chicago shout out
to the pride of chicago comedy scene
he is uh two golden brown english
muffins
slice of american cheese and a big old
sauce each give it up for t-bone
mcmuffin
toby mcmullen everybody what else kid's
got a big piece kid's got a big piece
and needs a haircut by the way
this kid's got a mop top on them uh and
all those tickets we sold in chicago are
people who i owe money
that's gonna be an awkward show and
looking for toby over there i said he
was gonna be on a show
but gang that's either here nor there we
could not be more excited to have our
incredibly
incredibly special guest back with us
again today
it's a family episode we got some
company we got some real company
we actually cleaned the place up a
little bit i took out the trash before
took out the trash
i did as og as it gets you know them you
love them
ladies and gentlemen give it up for mr
robert kelly yeah
it it it [ __ ] annoys me
[Laughter]
to no end the [ __ ]
just synergy you two [ __ ]
what do you mean i mean that was
flawless that was like
that was like a [ __ ] if i was gonna
do a movie and have guys
hey give it up for [ __ ] the cling
clean cling and a batch and mama's mom's
coming back and come see it and don't
forget big dick toby i owe money
all right let's do it i mean that was
flawless the kids got chemistry baby i
mean not
one [ __ ] misstep bing bang
it was one point where you were talking
there was a little gap and he jumped in
[ __ ] i mean i knew we were pissing
him off with that longing
it was the
[ __ ] polishness of you you guys are
[ __ ]
i mean we're cooking over here we're not
some bums they found in the village what
do you mean we've been doing this for a
while
a year
i've been doing it for 15. i was the
first one to have a podcast
[Laughter]
he's usually good for a flub in the
intro wow we got in here at noon and
started practicing
i mean that was whoa now does he get a
big dick because he's got a big big
piece
uncut big hog on him i'm gonna say this
unconfirmed i always
thought that i'll find out in raleigh
[Laughter]
sneaking into his room and [ __ ]
pulling his tiny whities down because
you know he wears teddy
absolutely nice she's a sheath guy right
here
that is that was the most fiendish [ __ ]
i've ever seen he just [ __ ] went
i love toby this is great we're having
fun folks
what's up guys buddy we're happy to have
you i like that he just keeps getting
better and better he looks amazing you
look
you look like time traveler bobby your
skin is fantastic yeah
i am [ __ ] i have the skin of a filipino
you look better now than you did in the
prior year i'm not [ __ ] on you you
look so bad
i mean it's a little bit everybody said
i look like [ __ ] then no no you look
so good now i have great skin dude yeah
i don't know what it is
the whole look the jacket the glasses
the glasses are nice you should have got
the big ones
but
yeah doesn't he look like from the
future
it looks like that guy from ocean the
oceans movies bobby 9123.
i don't know his name exactly you
couldn't get it i don't know
the guy from the ocean now he's just
murdered
you guys toby imdb him put it in post
that second when you got a good one
you're like the guy from the thing
i knew i wasn't gonna get it out i knew
you're talking about you're talking
about elliot gould
yes
yes or you could have went uh you gotta
be crazy to rob a casino
oh green i was banging cheerleaders two
at a time
that's not the quote but okay
i'm i'm not one of those i hate [ __ ]
stat people and
quote people stat people can hit the
[ __ ] bricks
i had that one time we got a guy who was
it jaymore walked up to me
uh hey were you a red sox fan yeah i
love the rest i'm from boston
yeah who's your center fielder i know i
hate that [ __ ] yeah
i don't give a [ __ ] i hate that the guy
with the the guy that looks
[ __ ] spanish
yeah i hate that too man it's like you
don't know enough about the team then
you're not a true fan
i don't know who the [ __ ] played i just
said outside linebacker for the eagles
in 78
but you know yeah you still enjoy the
enjoy the squad
yes i do i i love a team i love the pads
i love all why is it that we have to
love
it's very culty that you have to love
your teams from your town
i kind of like it though i don't like
when people like other teams from other
towns
but when where when are we when america
does something
like the olympics sure we all [ __ ] do
you gotta
yeah yeah it's us versus gotta beat
those chinese
i love that's gonna happen think they
got our number moving forward oh yeah
they just bought africa
they just signed the deal they own a lot
of [ __ ] they don't do the [ __ ] you're
doing this on their own oh yeah yeah
yeah pull our plug right now oh they'll
show we shut down all podcasts
the lights just go out
oh my god uh bobby thank you for coming
back folks if you haven't seen bobby's
episode please go back and check it out
it's absolutely [ __ ] amazing
uh real boston trash yeah right
that's the thing i was wondering was i
trash i forgot you weren't
classy i know that yeah
you'd have to say it you didn't win the
caviar awards
do you have caviar award no i don't if
you don't do an award show at the end of
your [ __ ] year
you're an [ __ ] that's pretty good you
don't have caviar caviar award
that's pretty good you just come up with
that yeah i did i got it i came up with
it no i think he did he said caviar wore
it i said make it a show
awards show i wouldn't get an executive
producer credit take it easy
i feel like i'm in a game of hungry
hungry hippos right now
jesus christ i got these two
chomping apps you get an award for the
most original fat joe
that was [ __ ] great you get you get a
[ __ ] cinnabon award for that
extra sauce oh my god frosting there it
is no right you know what i was thinking
about with boston
food oh sorry yeah what's for lunch
now you got me all jacked up i'm dying
for some marbles
what the [ __ ] is a fat [ __ ] i'm thinking
it's a pastry that i don't know about
from philly
i'm like he's like i gotta get down
there you gotta try marbles
[ __ ] gladys is down on [ __ ] south
street
oh [ __ ] ah the thing about boston is
uh so philly's trash inside the city yes
okay i mean there's some nice sections
but as far as like boston proper
it's a lot of money it's nice so you
really have to go to the whatever the
[ __ ]
why is it south shore right not not
anymore though what do you mean okay
because
when i was growing up boston proper yes
uh
newbury street all that [ __ ] comm ave
it's all
i'm talking like beacon hill the north
end oh yeah
the back bay that was all uh well the
north end was all italian it was the
[ __ ] mob so right
it was nice because they you know they
take care of their neighborhood but
right around it was um
real quick did someone tell you i had a
lobster roll at uh in the north end a
couple years ago at this place
on whatever that main strip is yeah it's
[ __ ] unbelievable
north end is fine unbelievable it's
[ __ ] they did not let anybody take it
over
it's still a lobster claw what's it
called still [ __ ] all italian people
over there yeah i mean they let people
sneak in here and there yeah but it's
still awesome
what it was when i left it's nice except
better but
around boston south boston charlestown
somerville
all that was you'd [ __ ] i got mugged
when i was eight
in charlestown really yeah the guy took
85 cents
big week for him i was going to the mall
meeting my friend 85 cents
what are you going to get i was just
going to the mall that's what you did
back then
you know what i mean i just went to the
mall that was the thing you went to the
park of the mall that's it you walked
around the mall
you maybe [ __ ] tried to squeeze an
orange julius out of somebody
and you sat at the fountain and tried to
[ __ ] you know look at some albums
that are coming out but
he took it i remember can i get 10 cents
back to call my mom and he threw me 10
cents
and i caught my mind oh you come pick me
up she's like where are you i just got
mugged at the uh
somerville charlestown area and she was
like yeah take a bus home i go i don't i
got my mom
walk home so but now it's [ __ ]
charlestown you can't it's nice all rich
southie all rich somerville yeah dude
it's all
all that all that i've stayed in
summerville somerville where i stayed
was nice like it's all right when i was
growing up i
can't tell you how many times i got the
[ __ ] kicked out
i mean [ __ ] for nothing other
than coming from medford really like
they'd be like where are you from
medford
and i would wake up like 20 minutes
later
that's such a dirtbag city thing like
what neighborhoods it's the
neighborhoods
like i hear i go home to i'll use him i
bet we'll be at the bar like drink with
my knucklehead cousins and they'll look
over and see like a group of kids making
noises like i bet the mayfair kids
you know i bet that kenzi like it's all
you're all bozos
you're all dirt balls you're all sitting
at the same shitty bar we had parks when
i was growing up
so you had a park that was your whatever
yeah like
oh that was your turf the italians were
tufts park what is it
it's like greece with bad news i'm from
somerville it was the 80s
no so the the irish kid at north park uh
car park uh the the black kids had
duggar park uh and then there was the
mix that was at playstat park
and the parks used to fight each other
so the parks used to fight each other
and the park i hung out was all the
italian kids they were [ __ ]
maniacs but some of them was right next
door so we would always bop over to
their park
and fight them and i remember i remember
once and i hated it i hated it so bad
because i just like to have fun
you know and uh we went over there one
day and we saw these three kids from
somerville in this little parking lot
behind these stores
and my friends i'm like here we go
[ __ ] fight the editor how old are we
talking
i i was uh i had to be 13. okay so we
watched
all my friends at 18 though 17 18
[ __ ] animals i mean
violent people i hung out with and uh so
but they were like hey you playing
wiffle ball let us play
all of a sudden we all stopped playing
together and we were all there was like
three kids with us and three kids with
them and kind of the same age
so the kid my age they were like hey you
two go get drinks or something at the
store
so we're like all right so me and this
kid went from somewhere we went and got
drinks we got snacks
so we're coming we're talking we're
laughing we're having like me and this
kid
hit it off yeah like i was planning a
trip to the mall next week
i did i love this kid and we're walking
back with snacks we're eating like
[ __ ] susie q's we got some
drink and we walk back and i just see a
kid's radio
flying in the flying in the air and it
just [ __ ]
boom hits the kid right and i'm like
here we go we drop the [ __ ] we just try
to fight each other
that's like when the two goalies in a
hockey they have no animosity yes
well i [ __ ] my team's rolling i gotta go
i was so sad it was
started out with a nice day some wiffle
ball some susie q's really liked you
sean but here we go
bob's
[Laughter]
you'd fight the parks would fight each
other parks would yeah
that's the thing too where you can sense
the fight coming you're like this is
like if you're so i was somewhere like
hanging out with comics who aren't
fighters but i was also hanging out with
my dirtbag friends right
like we were at a bar and i looked at
the i could just sense it like we was
going i'm like you guys
i told the comments you guys got to get
the [ __ ] out of here because shit's
going to go south quick oh i could i
said
two seconds after they left it just like
[ __ ] broke out i hung out the kids
out at my park i think the older kid was
like 35.
what oh dude he was what was in this
park you guys really like swing sets
nice merry-go-round it was a park during
the day and then at night we took it
over
and it that's where we drank and did
drugs and [ __ ] fought people
cops didn't [ __ ] with you cops did [ __ ]
with us but we would [ __ ] with them
so you know we'd have to switch sides of
the park you know what i mean they would
come down all the time and [ __ ] with
this
i remember i was such i was in trouble
and i was with the older kids
who were like [ __ ] creating mikey
catalano uh lonnie hilson these guys are
[ __ ]
such great names by the way mikey carano
will tune you up
jake jake gags joey gags joey anything i
mean he's good these guys
[Laughter]
yeah they were all 85 cents get on the
table yeah mikey oh
i love the names oh they were they were
so tough
and uh they would i remember one night
my three
uncles were their age too they came down
looking for me
and i was like over here i felt so bad
because my uncles came down where's
bobby
they were like who are you like we're
his uncles
yeah he's he's doing all right why don't
you take off he'll be home a little
later
jesus and they were like all right oh
no i saw your uncle's [ __ ] up well
blessed dude they were like come home i
was like yeah i'll be home a little
while i was a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
back then piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah
garbage cause you're so sweet now
oh bad kid back then but i didn't i
don't think i didn't want you you
weren't mugging people
i did you did better in life yeah i took
a moped
i remember i took not even a felony i
don't think that what's a moped set you
back couple of bucks
watch out this guy steals vespers keep
i'm talking about a moped when mopeds
came out damn you know what i mean there
was actually
on a bugatti yeah exactly this kid got a
moped and we were like this [ __ ]
we took it for a day we weren't [ __ ]
we'd give it back we just leave it on
your street somewhere sure sure but i i
mean years later i got sober i i'm um my
life is going great i went
i went to back to high school i
graduated i got a
scholarship to a bunker hill community
college for art i'm in english class
and my life is going great and all of a
sudden we're going around the room
and they're like uh you know hey i'm
blah blah blah and i looked at the kid
next to me i go hey i'm robert
he goes i know who you are and i went oh
[ __ ] it was the kid i took the moped
from
he was in my english class and he was
still mad yeah i'd be [ __ ] pissed too
hey you stole the kid's wheels yeah we
go to back he got back it was a little
dented up
he could have sold it he's got to
picture you at his house
i apologize we made that we're good man
i had a moped growing up pretty sweet
ride
mopeds are great yeah i don't care what
they say mopeds are [ __ ] great good
time yeah it's a fantastic
go-kart what do you do as far as uh uh
with max would you let max get a go-kart
or a moped or anything like that
you know that's funny in the future he's
still pretty young right what is he
i i would i just got him a segway like a
legitimate
segway with the big wheels well it's in
your legs
it comes up in between your legs oh yeah
yeah yeah but it's it's big wheels it's
not the little ones not the little yeah
not little [ __ ] ones people are dying on
that light on fire it's
from segway it's like big wheels and the
only reason i got it we're at somebody's
house who had it
and he jumped on it and just started
flying around i'm like [ __ ] it kid's got
it how old is hell does he know
he's uh he's going on eight seven going
on eight right now but yeah i'd get him
uh i get him a moped [ __ ] yeah what
about like a mini bike to ride around in
the backyard
we went up to maine right and i'm
sitting there talking to these people
because we're trying to we we're trying
to we're trying to get this tiny home
right lava tiny house lava [ __ ] my
wife wants monsters
those tiny homes of maine i know i've no
buddy i've been on this yes i'm well
aware
you gotta talk to those people they make
the best anyways
something you can't fit in
every house i don't want to be rude but
what are you doing bob customize it
he's got wide doorways it's like a [ __ ]
it's like a nice [ __ ] a [ __ ] no it's not
it's not home it's a [ __ ] home toilet
kitchen everything the thing is if it's
under a certain square foot in a lot of
places you don't have to pay
real estate taxes exactly and they're
[ __ ] i mean it's great
they're cool looking too we went up
there to get you know i went
way up to maine they're on like near the
canadian border and we're sitting down
in the home we're talking to this couple
they're the best couple ever
and young couple and i'm talking about
i'm trying to give my you know fi
well i let max do what he i don't want
to be afraid i let him do
what he wants to do and you know let him
you know venture out and be venturous
and stuff like that
and i i look and he max who's seven at
the [ __ ] time
is on a [ __ ] atv by himself flies by the
window
and i went max he's on it he goes i
thought you wanted him to be fearless
that's great i was just like yeah okay
and i just had to let eat my words and
let the kid [ __ ] zip around
an apple orchard on a [ __ ] atv i
meant like watch horror movies
that's such a city guy fear maybe put a
kid on a roof i don't know do you
remember
i mean i used to go on roofs all day
dude that's what i was i wanted to ask
you
like because you you were wild at a
young age i mean i was pretty
bananas i look back like i wouldn't want
a 20 year old doing the [ __ ] that we
used to do
dude roofs i mean we just like light
fire we just did crazy [ __ ] all the time
oh on the train tracks we would [ __ ]
around with tr
like we would bob this is it's a little
different we're talking
you're talking about the suburbs in the
early 90s 80s
no it's for him in early 80s in the city
in boston
stabbing i know i'm not saying i'm just
saying the [ __ ] you used to do compared
to this [ __ ] i'm gonna let my kids we
didn't [ __ ] stab anybody
okay you threw a couple eggs at the
mailman
this guy was living grease three over
here you were eating tasty cakes
i didn't say that i'm just saying this
we used to just go [ __ ] construction
sites we tried stealing tobacco we did
everything he was race rioting what are
you talking about no i'm not
i'm not saying i'm not not in boston
[Laughter]
was very segregated back then i uh i
remember one time
me and chris bracha who was my best
friend of the time
we got you know the uh pallets
okay but they used to make styrofoam
ones for pepsi yeah yeah yeah it was a
styrofoam big pallet
we got one of those and put it in the
mystic river
and we took that there's a real river
called the mystic river
there's a mystic river in method that
goes all the way into god i don't know
that sounds like narnia
sean penn mr griffin exactly that's
kevin bacon casey affleck
we we got in that and and took it all
the way out into the farm was the ocean
yeah we were little kids we just don't
know any better we got sticks and we got
this little boat and we were just in it
and i remember this it's a piece of
styrofoam
yeah we got a boat ma he paints her name
on the side
i got a sail the ss tiny home or
something
bobby's crabbing over there in the
harbor he's got a new ball
he's taking the whole family out this
weekend he's doing good
stay out of those crap parts you know
that's bill's livelihood
i caught you some susie q's ma hold on a
second there gang let's real quick talk
about
our favorite sponsor here on the podcast
sheath
underwear ladies and gentlemen fantastic
product
keeps everything nice and cozy and in
its place yeah guys if you're not
familiar it's a two
pouch system they got going they got a
pouch for your balls a pouch for your
wee-wee
you can put your wee-wee in one pouch
the other pad it doesn't mean go no
pouch one pouch two pouch whatever you
want baby you can do keeps your boys
all nice and in the right place it's
also the most comfortable minus that
the the fabric is fantastic it's
breathable it's modal spandex it's the
whole thing they got cool
you feel sexy in them i gotta say i
agree i feel i feel like an underwear
model i feel like i should be along in
the box of one of these things they're
great
invented and owned by an iraqi war
veteran yeah
shout out to who's the go-to guy i email
with him he's a hands-on [ __ ] guy he
loves comedy podcasts he supports a lot
of comedy podcasts and he [ __ ] loves
the show so support them guys go to
sheathunderware.com
use promo code garbage for 20 off your
next purchase
it's fantastic give it a shot what's the
worst that can happen
you feel good that's it it will be the
best pair of underwear you ever
put on 100 guarantee it guys sheath
underwear dot com use promo code garbage
let's face it gang taking trips to the
post office is no
fun way to spend your time that's why we
have a solution for you
with our sponsor here on the show
stamps.com
we are recommending stamps.com to
everybody
it allows you to mail and ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer
you can send letters you can send
packages and you pay a lot less with
discount rates
from usps and ups and more
crazy stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands
thousands of hours and tons of money
with stamps.com you get the service of
the post office
and ups all in one place not to mention
that you got big discounts on mailing
and shipping rates
yeah guys it's a fantastic products
product service we use it uh we use it
to send out our merch
if you're a small business owner you can
use it to send out invoices you can send
out products
whatever you need to do you need a
printer you need some wi-fi and a
computer i don't care if you work from
your house if you work from an office
if you're in the basement of ant hoodies
if you're in your new kia forte whatever
you're in
go to stamps.com and get involved
um stance ifcom is a no-brainer saves
you time and money no wonder there's
over a million small businesses that use
stamps.com so stop wasting time
by going to the post office and use
stamps.com there's no risk use our promo
code garbage
when you get there for a special offer
that includes a four-week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale
and buddy no long-term commitment at all
fantastic uh just go to stamps.com click
on the microphone at the top of the home
page and type in our code
garbage at stamps.com never go to the
post office again
finally gang real quick we want to talk
to you about the good time uncle hank
and aunt kippy are having over there
on the stereo app usually every
thursdays at nine o'clock
we're chopping it up and we're taking
your questions yeah guys it's a super
cool app
it's like a live stream uh you get to
ask us your garbage questions
uh you get to record them live we play
them live we answer it
i have a couple of beers it's a fun time
it's like a little bit of an after party
so
use the link in the description
www.stereo.com
kevinryan or slash h foley sure we get
to wet our beaks a little bit sign up
it's a good time we'll see you there
peace back to the show
jesus christ yeah back down to the ocean
dude we almost went to the ocean this
boat drove by and when you
[ __ ] are you doing it and i remember
they towed us back they didn't even let
us get in their boat
they threw a robot we were just holding
it me and chris and water was coming up
into the thing
and we were [ __ ] getting scared dude
jesus we did a lot of [ __ ] we used to
climb the roofs of the churches
oh yeah we go on like school roofs and
stuff yeah yeah it was [ __ ]
you have nothing to do especially in the
suburbs and there's no one around you
can just
and your parents never never were around
i was the last generation i think that
would like leave the house
i was born in 86 and i would leave the
house in the summer right for like you
know
[ __ ] 18 hours hours and then just
come back and my mom would be like call
at six to check in yeah call for
whatever pay phone or whatever house i
was about to come here
i wonder what i mean kids were getting
[ __ ] murdered and taken back then
sure yeah like crazy like there's i was
just thinking that like it's gonna be
tough for there to be like a real serial
killer or like abduction ring going on
now back in the 80s 70s 80s that should
happen all the time but but it happened
all the time but there was no
it was local news so you really didn't
find out about it
you just they used to give like 48 hours
for a kid and then that was it
like well timmy didn't come home yeah
that was a move on he's gonna
have another kid repainted that's why
they had like eight kids yeah
because one of them's gonna die i
remember adam was the big one remember
that kid
that's when they switched everything up
and they started doing milk cartons yeah
that's that was the first twitter that
was like when they did that
[ __ ] right you'll never see a missing
kid on a carton of oat milk
no yeah you see a fat guy on the side
[Laughter]
so you got milk they get all kinds of
milk now they got oat yeah you didn't
know that
where are they getting how do you get
milk from an oat i don't know you soak
it in water or something like that
water soak it in water do you get water
dude
get a table but adam is when that was
when i was real young we all had to go
and get fingerprinted
do you remember that you you're too
young dude
what are you talking about i got
fingerprinted are you rich no
[Laughter]
you sound like a narc to me who goes and
who goes and cooperates at a young age
we all had to go get fingerprinted at
the sears because they were
serious don't do fingerprints yeah they
do mom tell them
my mom will back me up on this that kid
john walsh's son got kidnapped and they
found them
yeah all right
they found part of them and then the
other part later yeah poor bad poor kid
um but then that caused like a nice
nationwide wave
of you know of kids getting kidnapped
right so they had us all go get
fingerprinted
in case in case you got kidnapped right
i don't remember that
it was the 90s probably got a chip in or
something
dude i don't remember i mean
fingerprinting i got fingerprinted when
i was
uh yeah they already had yours
here comes bobby kelly again
you were a second floor man i was
setting it up i was right there and he
stepped right on it with a better one
three decker men at best ah hang on i
gotta suck on my tongue i get some
moisture
[Laughter]
here i have some my coffee oh my god i
told his mountain dew right behind you
i'm not gonna drink mountain [ __ ]
dude who drinks mountain dew what about
that you can have that soda up there
that soda's from my
when i was a kid he stole that yeah i'm
not [ __ ] touching that
why don't you just offer me some of that
[ __ ] skippy
[Laughter]
shout out to the fan that sent that in
hippie by the way skippy bobby look
kippy
oh that's my nickname kippy i know i
know okay i wasn't sure no i totally got
it i just didn't laugh
oh yay but i did get it before we get
into the patreon questions
yes i have to know what i don't
understand what's what's the tiny house
what are we talking about a tiny house
is this okay you own a home
i own a i own my home right westchester
right for himself does well
right i'm very modest i have a nice
little
ranch whatever but then uh i bought land
in new hampshire very cheap did you
yes okay and then we were gonna build
trying to subdivide i got a couple of
bucks now
you can have a little time how many
acres well tiny house comm you know
a lot of people are doing that yeah
two and a half acres no i can't swing on
anything
chewing the two girls and bobby sleeping
no the um two and a half acres but
behind it is 600 acres of forest
damn so it's you know that you know but
it's up in the white mountains of new
hampshire so which we've all we go to
every year for 30 years
we've been going up there so i was like
let's just buy the land
and see what happens and then we got all
of a sudden i was on
uh was it instagram and i saw the tiny
homes in maine i was like this is great
yeah because um you know some of these
little things
you know you buy a prefab house it's a
[ __ ] house
it's just garbage i didn't want to get
we were thinking about getting a trailer
it's like that's doof
yeah nobody wants that and they're cool
they're cool looking they're [ __ ]
what do you want to do what do you want
to do
now clint eastwood any which way but
loose you know what i mean
right turn clyde you [ __ ] loser i
haven't even seen that i don't know what
you you never saw
in black and white i didn't know what
the [ __ ] he was talking about but it was
a funny name so i ran with him and he
literally
and he went between never saw the
[ __ ]
vehicle for clint eastwood any which way
but
loose with the orangutan
sounds like a blockbuster hit though it
was dude it was
and that was the one where you know that
blonde girl he had in all his movies for
a little bit
do you know clint eastwood at all i know
i relax i know this is
forgiven come on what am i an [ __ ]
that came out my senior high school
i just don't know that i don't know that
stuff the offbeat stuff i know high
plains drifter i know pale ryder
i know dirty happens in between in
between
there was there was this moment in time
where in between the
spaghetti westerns and like the dirty
harry
and later on what we know is him there
was this
silly [ __ ] i believe it was in
between her the silly
fun clint eastwood he's always doing
comedies good
hilarious comedies really let's back up
not hilarious
i mean there's
any which way but loose in any which way
you can i believe is the two of them
and it's like ernest goes to camp goes
to school he took uh he took the [ __ ]
orangutan in the zoo to get laid
know in the middle of the night he would
just break into a zoo so he'd get some
[ __ ]
orangutan it's got a 37 on rotten
tomatoes
the critic's consensus is the
inexplicable pairing of clint eastwood
with an orangutan is the least of any
which way but loses problems
yeah okay but go to the other one what's
the other one any which way you can i
believe that's a good one now that
that was a little better they they
polished up the hitches
figured it out they had a tune-up game
beforehand they tweaked the script
oh it's so and everybody's in it too
it's like a cannonball run time
okay cannonball run i know great movie
love great movie cannonball run one and
two
correct it's in that time when they're
making those movies those kinds of
movies sure
that that movie would feel like i'm
hanging out with my uncles
this one's even worse it's got a twenty
percent [ __ ] about it oh you know what
the first one was better
never can't catch magic in a bottle
twice now where do you see a movie like
that a young kid bobby kelly out with
his
uh 25 year old friends you glad you guys
go to the movies during the day you
sneak in
dude no we didn't stab the ticket guy
what happens
going to the movies back in the day was
an event it wasn't like a thing he just
went to like now people go to the movies
i mean before this [ __ ] you just went to
the movies you wouldn't go to the movies
during the day
no because you didn't no i was doing
[ __ ] drugs and [ __ ] you know
drinking we were we were trying to hang
out you didn't go to you went to the
movies with your family you went to the
movies on vacation
you
[Laughter]
you have a puddle i could see
we forgot to get drinks i'm going to
mail you a case of water yeah i don't
need you to me i just need one now i
don't i got a house
i got i got a [ __ ] fountain people
you got anything floating over
a red bull i mean jesus christ i mean i
take a little piss in a cup
listen not like an arrangement um
yeah what do you do up in this plate
what are you doing
you go camping up there for the last 30
years well my uncle
back around 30 years ago bought a piece
of land up where i bought land on the
same street up on squan lake where uh on
golden palm do you know one golden pond
the movie
is that too much for you yes i don't
want you you never saw on gold the pond
no
i mean what the [ __ ] i i i i i don't
know what to say he's a young kid bobby
what are you doing
i'm 34. that's not young that's middle
age
what year did this movie come out it
came out when when you were alive
when i don't know i just told you
it was uh henry fonda henry fonda and
his daughter
yeah jane fonda jane fonda i mean she's
old to me i definitely don't know her
dad
well that's why i wouldn't i know the
movie but i didn't see it and my family
was not big fans of jane fonda
of course no one is they have they have
uh what's his name
hank no what's the guy tell them alvin
payne on jane fonda
on their house on the house i've never
seen a house with a bumper sticker
it's the trashiest thing i've ever seen
in my life they have it on the patio
door i just want to let you know what
you're in for when you walk in that
house
it's going to be [ __ ] rainbow
suspenders and hard hats
oh they don't play around yeah listen
well anyways it's up there we've been
going up there for years my uncles three
uncles bought
land up there years ago they would camp
on it then they built a little house on
it
okay then they made a nicer house and
then my uncle
bought the other two out because they
stopped going and built a
[ __ ] beautiful mansion nice i mean
i mean chipping green a golf course an
archery range
a guest house he's got no i mean he's
just real why don't you just get in on
that one
well i well he wants to do his own thing
well i was i was a guest there for a
long time he has a guest house
and we would always go up there right
and me and i was like you know what
let we need to stop being guests i don't
want my kid to be a guest
yeah it's tough i want a tough look with
kids i feel like it's like i want my kid
i can't go and do what he did like i
don't have the money to buy a house
but we can buy a little piece of land
and we can make sure there's land behind
it
which gives us more land than we
actually paid for you know technically
you can [ __ ] whap back there and
crank one out in the woods sure yeah
right and uh and then we found this
thing and it's like
tiny homes is not that expensive no you
can get like 79
000 for a house yeah and they wheel it
on and you plug it in
and you're good to go i mean it's a
little more than that but
i'm a big fan of it man yeah you can go
totally off grid too though you
literally can
plug these in have water delivered to a
thing and then
yeah and you can be totally off grid on
these things it has a compost toilet
you're just [ __ ] it and change out
the thing every
throw in the woods every three weeks or
whatever like that so my wife won't do
that she's
she'll buy she won't [ __ ] in anything
but a toilet so we have to get like real
plumbing but
how are you gonna do that we don't do it
the guys who do it do it but you just
like a septic tank septic
exactly okay yeah you gotta get when you
get a when you buy land if you build you
got to get
a well to get water and you have to get
a septic tank and a leech field
which we found out well water we thought
was trashy we didn't grow up with well
water
it's not though they say it's the best
because it's like naturally filtered
through stone or
it's coming out of the [ __ ] it's
literally i don't know coming out of the
ground you're getting something that's
been in a pipe for 200 years yeah
you got inside that i run it through the
brita
the what the brita the the britta britta
british doesn't have that you've taken
the filter out probably three years ago
and never
played you don't have to really remember
your looks like a fish tank
little scuba guy in it yeah little
treasure chest
yeah sorry so that's that's what it is
i'm a big fan
go for it and you want this to be this
you wanted to be your primary residence
you guys are looking at
a vacation home you know about it away
can i just say you know being in this
business
you need i mean we've been in this
business for like three months by the
way so let's not get ahead
but as a comic in your head there's
always that we can just go live the
[ __ ] signing
for eight bucks a month yeah i'll
[ __ ] do shows at a a
deli i'll panhandle on the [ __ ] fly
fishing spot
and make money you know what i mean
there's always that little thing gotcha
yeah gotta get away gotcha plus when the
race was happening a couple months
i have a place to go the cities are
getting dicey oh it's getting dicey i
just i i literally bought this
it's [ __ ] nuts up there why a knife
though are you really going to stab
somebody i think if he needs to he will
yes bobby is
a little [ __ ] but do you think you'll
be this guy's bonkers
if somebody was going to hurt if
someone's coming at him yeah it's like a
punch i wouldn't want to do it i mean
you say i wouldn't i would never even
want to but if somebody was going to
hurt me yeah you're going to slash
you're going to stab
i'm not going to slash i'm not poke
michael jackson you [ __ ] get him put
it right in his thigh
i'm going to go down to the ground and
cut his achilles and he's going to come
chase me and he can't
yeah i'm going to still catches you that
would suck
did you ever have i had a friend of mine
a comic i'm gonna get a 10 second head
start
this happened in l.a this was [ __ ]
terrible
he was coming out of a 7-eleven uh wayne
previtt [ __ ] great guy passed away
last year but uh he's coming out of a
7-eleven this homeless guy la you know
they're so aggressive out there
started getting his face and he found
he's like listen get the [ __ ] out of my
face
i'm going to beat the [ __ ] out of you
this guy [ __ ] you still in his face
so he starts beating the [ __ ] out of
this homeless guy okay and
all of a sudden he goes to kick him and
he breaks his ankle
he falls to the ground in pain and he
can't move he's in so much pain he's
just lying on the ground screaming
and he goes then all of a sudden i just
felt something climbing up my body
it was the homeless guy he climbed up
all the way to his face nose to nose and
went
i got you now [ __ ] that's gonna
haunt myself just a breath
on you i would have passed out so you
never [ __ ] know
i mean he was he was [ __ ] killing it
and then he broke his dumb ankle
you gotta get out while you're ahead
this guy needs some milk or something
[Laughter]
oh yeah yeah holy [ __ ] all right let's
get into some [ __ ] patreon questions
we got bobby here bobby thank you so
much for coming out
hot up so far hot up great app love
having bobby
um yeah so guys when you sign up for
patreon uh we will ask your garbage
question it's the best way to do it uh
we just get so many requests otherwise
that uh so when you join we will answer
your garbage questions
this isn't even a garbage question this
came up this is a jumping off point this
came up
last episode and was very [ __ ]
divisive in the comments you're you're
in new york
right like you've been in new york for
what like 20 years or something at this
point a long time
25 years 25 years 25 years 25 years new
yorker yeah i always consider myself in
new york and you're uh you're uh you
know you liked it
this you're you're a food guy you like
your food a certain way
not this is not this i get you you see
what you you have you have really
appreciate i appreciate you yes i
appreciate you pulling back on the
uh that's not has nowhere nowhere where
he knows his way around a twinkie
all right so you get a didn't expect it
from chubby finger
i'm out of control um you go to a new
york bagel place for
breakfast ah yeah all right excellent
you have your one right yeah i have one
in my house yeah okay do you get that
it's a fresh bagel made that day
okay what do you like what do you like
sesame seeds hold on first of all
are you getting a bag to go are you
getting one for yourself or have them
make it up
are you getting the like the quarter
pound of cream cheese oh dude
look i go i have three people i gotta
buy bagels for i get a dozen bagels
okay and i give them to the neighbors i
i go over with bags i got some bagels if
we don't eat them
i go and i bring them over so you're not
getting just a sandwich by yourself
no okay well let's just say you were by
yourself you're you're you know you're
just by yourself
i'm by myself you're by yourself you
want a bagel i want a bagel you want a
bagel you're like i'm going i'm going to
eat it in the car or whatever i'm just
having it this is my breakfast i'm going
to the city for the day to do whatever
okay
do you get that bagel toasted it's fresh
made that day do you get it toasted
or no i don't
hit me yes it's cause it's that good
right when you get a fresh
egg bagel if you tell them if you toast
it you
[ __ ] ruin it you ruin it you ruin it
you're not getting the
moisture the the the softness the the
the warmth it's like a hug when it goes
in your mouth
when it hits you a little chubby and if
and then you bite down and then it goes
between your teeth
and then it's stuck a little bit oh [ __ ]
that's the way to do it we've been
getting
we've been called coastal elites the
whole [ __ ] all week because of saying
that it's like
new york if you get a fresh new york
bagel or even philly or you know a fresh
east coast bagel you can't get a toast
it ruins it no
not from a bagel place of course if you
go to a deli or something it's different
because it's not fresh made that yeah
you got to toast it to make it right yes
100 if you're at a bagel place if your
bagel's coming out of a bag you got to
toast it
if that thing is sure you eat that
[ __ ] right then
all right just wanted to see where you
stand absolutely that's the right answer
by the way thank you very much
i'm glad i got the right answer do you
eat in the car do i eat in the car yeah
absolutely okay yeah stay in the car
absolutely yeah
so you stop somewhere you're driving
down you're having a little nosh
if i do i stop and eat or do i drive and
eat drive and eat
i [ __ ] drive and eat absolutely
there's nothing better turkey dinner on
nothing better than thank you having
that having that sandwich
and there's the bites are like the
papers perfectly aligned
and there's no thinking you can just you
don't have to look you can just do it
it's big
sports talk radio or something
sparkling water that's not coming out of
production expenses by the way
did you get a coffee too jesus christ
you got a whole accoutrement yeah yellow
shot or something you know
look at i love him t-bone's the man i'm
so jealous you you work with him you
know i love him right
what's with the shot what's going on
that's a tiny cup of almond of oat milk
so that bobby can try it for the first
time
for the first time what'd you put in the
coffee what cream
i think no no the coffee is black i'm in
this no no the coffee's but i don't like
your coffee so the coffee is black
now the coffee ain't black i've got news
for you there's stuff in it yeah there's
something a little lighter oh she [ __ ]
up she gave me the
she's she mislabeled the [ __ ] oh okay
yours is yours
i'm sorry i touched it but i didn't
touch the cup it's all right they got
the vaccine yeah we're all right and
i don't have it i think t-bone's bucking
for i know looking for a new gig here
well i don't like this one what the
[ __ ] i never got a coffee yeah t-bone
stay here trust me
stay here i want to come i want to let's
just put let me do t-bones
you know how to do subtitles you're
hired yeah [ __ ] subtitles
oh i hate the clock sucker we should do
subtitles everybody's going to do
subtitles your manager you're doing it
you should do subtitles
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] off driving me
crazy there you go
now you got a coffee and you got a water
yeah i knew that's where you were going
i love it power moved by t-bone
it's a fuss flex on these looks look at
him [ __ ] two drinks kelly over here
from nothing to something i've been
talking for 45 minutes with nothing in
my mouth except my own saliva
did you try the book bobby what do you
think um i didn't show a little i'm
three boning
[Laughter]
that is [ __ ] good yeah it's good
right they know what they're doing
is the big company oatley that's like
drinking oatmeal yeah
oatley is the big company i mean that's
not that's not the
craziest thing to say it's oatmeal a lot
of celebs are invested in that company
so if you have a little left over from
the tiny house
you could drop a little in there what
the [ __ ] a lot of
a lot of famous people are investing in
that company i'm in the no what do you
want i'm in the no
i'm gonna go [ __ ] my wife would kill
me i got no [ __ ] money i just bought
a
dump tiny house in a [ __ ] plot of
land you want to invest in
what go [ __ ] yourself go make money fat
boy go back on the road and
sell oh sorry go ahead so that being
said we'll be in raleigh nashville
chicago and it's right
get those tickets baby all right let's
get into some [ __ ]
chicago when uh june 21st or something
like that
i don't know i shouldn't know this
because i'm in chicago too that would
have been great if we were both there
oh we'd love that link up you're doing
the uh the laugh factory right
laugh factory yeah what up yeah this guy
[ __ ] knows where he knows every movie
he's speaking who are you
whose side are you on yeah what's going
on here everybody's sizing oh
he's got a non-compete clause i mean
he's he's got a
he's man listen first of all i had toby
first okay
he's not wrong bobby really helped me
change my life a little bit yeah i know
my guy first that you guys [ __ ] stole
she sure did
meet me in the pack you go tell
everybody in the pack too we got toby
all right toby's running with the boys
now they got to mikey home
thank you hey jimmy gags they got
t-boned jake they got t-bone
i'm gonna give him a cool nickname too
yeah bring your camera and some brass
knuckles
i'm [ __ ] loving this
[Laughter]
i thought you told me to take a sip of
it he's drinking like it's a nip of
fireball
that's why i love japanese oh i love
those yeah anything like that yeah it's
adorable oh my god
what's that face did i just get canceled
for saying that no no they're good at
engineering and stuff like that and
packaging
i love that um all right let's get into
it these are the patreon questions
uh garbage questions for baby kelly
uh all right first one coming in and you
as a kid and then also now that you're
you you know for max that you're you're
a dad um
did your parents let you curse as a kid
no no no would you let it fly and then
get in trouble or was it like you just
knew not even across the line you don't
i mean i did i mean you know i mean i
did [ __ ] up i wonder
of course i wound up cursing you were
bad on the outside you weren't bad in
the house
like you weren't badly your mom were you
no no like i had a big irish catholic
family i had my grandmother my
grandfather and 13 of us
13 of us lived in a three bedroom for a
long time
a long part of my life so i had a really
i have a great family five uncles two
aunts
my grandfather and grandmother so i
never i never [ __ ] around in front of
them yeah
but you know my mom got married to this
other guy
who was an [ __ ] right and then i kind
of turned was he in the house with his
with the 13 people no we moved out
that's when we moved out and that's what
kind of things went to [ __ ] right so
uh you know i started hanging out with
the wrong crew blah blah blah blah and i
wound up
swearing but i think also coming from
boston you use [ __ ]
in the middle of a word it's the same
yeah it's the same thing it's like
it's so i curse too much yeah it's like
in my set i swear a lot
and i don't have to but it's that's how
you rhythmically talk
it's how i talk [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm
this [ __ ] guy [ __ ] second
[ __ ] yeah you know it just comes
out that way you know how do you curse
in front of max
i try not to but he loves chris you
catch your finger in the grill or
something like that yeah
yeah like a box this morning she left
the box in the hallway that blocks
though you gotta
do a tightrope to get through the
[ __ ] hallway and i tripped over it
seven times
and i was like [ __ ] box [ __ ] and then
i got called
he'll come up be like dad but he likes
to swear a lot
what's he saying what's his go-to i we
just went to a
i'll play this video if you want we just
went to the amusement park
out in uh uh uh american dream by giant
stadium
okay uh have you heard of that is that
the new one indoor one the water park
it's
huge water park it's that new mall they
built like right next to giant stadium
oh really it's off the turnpike
or off yeah also turnpike amusement they
got a water park and music the water
park comes out of the building and comes
back in you see it i drive by it's up by
the bridge you go skiing they have a ski
slope
so we go on the thing he doesn't want to
go on the roller coaster i'm like listen
you go on the roller coaster
and i go you can swear i can swear one
time he goes
four i go i go two [ __ ] quack second
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
he goes i go two he goes three i go out
three times so we go down the roller
coaster
[Applause]
he's clear how much uh not a lot
oh jesus
[Applause]
[Applause]
he's letting him fly
here's this video of me being a [ __ ]
put a couple of dirt balls
17 shits by the way the other families
were like look though wait is this
outside the roller coaster is inside
you're [ __ ] so ghetto you're still on
the inside [ __ ] yeah he can't
they didn't do much as a family i mean
he's like he's learning a lot
wait a minute this is inside yeah now
bobby he thought
the entire epcot center was inside the
ball he swear the sword of god
up until last week oh my god i've never
been there the ball's not even that big
i've never been i thought it was the
size of orlando apparently
that's what i thought it was talking
about anytime somebody says epcot center
it's that [ __ ]
uh golf ball that's right every time
they say paris they show the [ __ ]
eiffel tower doesn't mean it's the whole
[ __ ] city
yeah nobody said epcot center in 15
years by the way
since they opened universal oh is that
what it's called
universal no it's a new one it's a new
one it's way better it's like way better
than
you can literally get [ __ ]
grasshopper frog chocolates and
fly on harry potter's train and and it's
crazy you can do
what the [ __ ] grasshopper fly chocolates
good you can go
to harry potter's village right i'm not
even kidding you buy a wand
i'm a wizard
i'm gonna go fight in the pack bring
your wand
with my wand ips no
what i can't say voldemort i'll say it i
don't care i'm not scared
some kid from slytherin got cut up real
good
he sliced his [ __ ] throat they found
him over in the pack
bunch of susie q's all over them i think
it was bobby what's a suzy kid that's
what he said
you don't know what a suzy q is
shoehorned into five jokes what is it
what's high
it was the name of a dry cleaner in my
neighborhood you know what a ring ding
is
yeah all right you know what a are you
who is are you like a
the milk you who no not a yodel you know
what a yoda list [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you familiar with drake's a yodel
pastry line yeah well that's what he's
saying
and a ring ding very similar just
different shapes am i right
you are wrong and that no a ring ding is
round and covered in chocolate a yodel
doesn't have any chocolate chips oh no
you're right what the ding dong is what
i'm talking about ding dong's clothes
the ding-dong has is a similar chocolate
on the outside similar to the ring
isn't it more of a ring but now you have
now here's the thing
you you have the the the ding-dong and
the
the the couple very very very exhausted
it's too much it's too rich i love it
but then you have the
the devil dog too dry sure i made a shoe
drive but then you have
the suzuki yeah i got you right here
right oh it's like the
and it's not dry but it's not too rich
and it comes with two big five
you should you when i was a kid it came
with two it's a [ __ ] deal
so i always went i always win susie q
pop one of those in the freezer i didn't
know him
oh [ __ ] i've never thought of
that in my life
you fat genius i've never thought of it
it's like picasso some say
this he's in his frozen period right now
who the why didn't i think of that
that's
the first guy he freezes everything you
can say anything you'd be like do you
ever have a jolly rancher
you get a whole section you got a whole
second life out of snacks by putting
them in the freezer
my nephew told me last night i put him
in the freezer two weeks not too bad
my nephew told me to put sour patch kids
in i like that thank you i
almost spilled his coffee
[Laughter]
all right we're having a good time all
right let's get let's uh let's keep
moving here
um this is from casey uh it's inside huh
you've never been to an inside amusement
park dude he's never been
inside an amusement park at somebody's
house why don't you why don't you make a
day of it why don't you go
we didn't notice existed i knew it
existed my mind wasn't blown by it i
believe
i've never driven by a mall i'm like i
should take foley there i just assume
you've been to one before
they're opening a comedy club in that
mall yeah i know who is
who is it i don't should we say why not
i was told not to
right then don't buy the person well
then don't okay
why why would you need a dad talk
should i say they told me not to buy the
birth no then you're
okay i wasn't sure if we were living on
the edge or something did you ever watch
a mob
movie in your life jesus christ what
part of town are you from should i tell
everybody
they told me not to but i will if you
say so should i tell the cops we killed
this guy
what do you think boss should i go tell
him bobby said not to
bobby said not to but i'm gonna go tell
him anyway oh man
it's so hard so funny to see him fight
his shitty philly accent
to do my accent your mouth fails in the
middle of it
i'm not good at either one of them yeah
so what's up i found from doing the show
more my philly accent comes out even
more which is not good
um all right this is from casey have you
ever used a butter knife to unscrew
something
okay of course yeah do you ever pull
that one out of the drawer and it's bent
while you're trying to cut chicken or
something
yeah it's like twisted at the end well i
like here's the thing though butter
knives changed cause the [ __ ] yuppie
[ __ ]
they tried to make a butter knife take
it easy yeah jesus was like on the
oatley will you
and he's [ __ ] how did yuppies change
butter knives because
a butter knife used to be because that
was the the root of all evil when he was
a kid
the big round one it was a round at the
end the big guy
now they tried to make him pointy so
it's a half butter knife you could use
it for chicken yeah
not steak but chicken or pork you can
use the so you have one knife that does
everything which is [ __ ]
i like a nice there's nothing like a
butter i can only drink out of a
certain cup for coffee i have to have a
separate cup for tea
i can't drink out of anything what's the
difference of the cups well a tea cup i
like it to be a little
bigger because i want you know tea you
wrap down a little bit
a coffee cup i like to be a little
smaller because i don't want you know i
like a nice
good cup of coffee but not too much
excuse me i like it he's got his reasons
as long as somebody can back something
up i'm fine with it the butter knife
i like when it's a big guy you get a
nice spread to it you get a spread
it's not going to hurt anybody you know
what i mean you keep your butter in the
fridge or in the
on the counter what no who the [ __ ]
wants to
scrape it like ice like it's come on
hawaiian ice insult them with that
question you you keep it on the counter
like a [ __ ] human being
overnight yes yeah you do you have a
butter tray
oh you're just leaving it out what am i
a [ __ ] yuppie butter tray
dude a butter tray is not yuppie that's
been around since the [ __ ] dude
it's a it's a big thing on the podcast
putting you're putting your
butter in the fridge or keep it on the
counter butter on the counter
with a butter tray yes of course i just
that's for requests
that's for rich people and you should
only do the irish butter
if you're a good person the kerrigans
yeah
kerrigan's butters kerrygold kerrygold i
don't know why there's any whatever the
[ __ ] it is
well there's other but i'm using an
irish cherry kerrygold is the rayo's of
butter
you can't go back yeah i had some i had
some on sunday we did a corn we did the
corn beef and cabbage at my brothers for
saint patty's day sounds like a nice
breakfast oh it was great
i like that thanks hey he's too slow
sometimes he's just slow
when he's talking about food or family
he zones comedy out and just gets stuck
on it
um all right this is from frank how long
have you used a phone with a cracked
screen
i i not that long i mean i am [ __ ]
chat i don't have a bottom of my phone
look at that
bobby she fell off the other day i
immediately get a fix you're a big
technology guy i just
i i i just i i'm in a bad way i love the
iphone when the iphone came out
i i'm such a nerd i was like they
finally did it
they they did it and i love the iphone
so much
you do oh i love the [ __ ] the just
everything it does
is just cra everything i left the house
the other day without my wallet
my wallet's on the back right here i
left without that wait is that stuck to
it it's a magnet it's a magnet my wife's
got the same thing
it's the best [ __ ] right i would
never be such a gadget
mag back wallet case sponsor these
[ __ ] podcast mag back
wouldn't you worry about it's falling
doesn't fall huh no it doesn't fall wow
bobby has never said no to you look at
that
yeah it looks pretty good yeah and this
is magnet too so you can stick it on the
[ __ ]
uh you know wherever sure but yeah i i
went out of the house with just this the
other day
and i bought everything i needed with
just my phone that's i'm just learning
how to do that it's pretty [ __ ]
important to pay
well yeah all of it yeah it's awesome
yeah
um right remember where you are when you
first saw the iphone i love that when
something hits his brain
it just comes out oh yeah we were
talking all of a sudden he went apple
pay
i got the chip right he's more of a
candy apple pay kind of guy but
i love a candy apple zoom in on that
typo i love a candy apple
you a candy apple guy bobby i i i
[ __ ] despise it
real it is the worst snack yes thank you
it is [ __ ] it was made for horses
somebody didn't get one at the fair
that's why look i always got them and
you you eat them and you might as well
[ __ ] rip your teeth out
and then you're eating an apple it's a
[ __ ] apple yeah the candy's going
quick
is there a lettuce apple a candy apple
and what the [ __ ] is that
lettuce what about a caramel apple you
like a caramel apple i don't like
apples and [ __ ] that stupid snack
sucks a bag of dicks the only one that
i'll [ __ ] allow
is the one that they just dip in
chocolate like nine times
oh they do that they dip it in chocolate
and then they pour [ __ ] on it
that out i might do that that sounds
like my [ __ ] wheelhouse right there
when you bite into a caramel apple your
[ __ ] teeth and they say
it's all over here and [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
out of here it's always that [ __ ] apple
too yeah what are you hanging out at a
[ __ ]
granny smith it's it's that it's that
[ __ ] one they never get though
what's the red delicious red delicious
is garbage i'm a gran
i'm the i've recently turned as i got
older turned into the green guy
i'm a granny smith guy i don't know a
granny smith can go [ __ ] i'd
rather eat the broad i'd rather i'd
rather you the old lady's vagina
get over here pull your shirt up though
i literally make the same face
it does get you back here it gets you in
the jowls a little bit
oh man all right all right next one this
is i've had this well this is from ryan
have your parents ever purchased your
birthday cake while they were grocery
shopping with you
oh yeah like have you ever been standing
there like go grab a cake for your
birthday
i remember one i remember once it's a
sad look that's all i remember i
remember
one birthday and i got in trouble and i
remember being on the stairs crying
that's all i remember you only remember
one birthday i don't let me think let me
let me
let me really think back
no i don't remember i don't remember as
a kid having a birthday
damn i'm sure it happened toby go grab a
birthday cake
he's just angling for us to get him a
birthday cake ah you spelled bobby wrong
god damn it i'm sure it did but i don't
think a birthday cake can be like
vanilla i mean i wanted chocolate but
it's pretty good
i like vanilla what is your cake by the
way
yellow cake with uh milk milk chocolate
frosting with chocolate frosting yellow
yellow cake but here's the thing my wife
makes it it is
the best cake on the planet it's yellow
cake but she puts
jello in it to make it moist i don't
understand it but i don't hate it
so and then of course the chocolate milk
jello pudding
the pudding in it she puts pudding in it
and it makes it
it makes it i thought you meant like
green jelly
all right
[Laughter]
i've heard enough i'll tell you why my
wife makes a [ __ ] uh fourth
generation
stuffing from her grandmother's her
mother's
great-grandpa whoever the [ __ ] it was
some old broad
i don't think stuffing's been around for
four generations
[Laughter]
i mean dude it's the best is there
sausage in it of course there is
that's different than this sausages
sausage
breakfast that's the way to go that's
what my mom does that's the way to do it
breakfast sausage
has a spice in it yeah that's got the
little orange flakes
there's something in it that makes sense
you mean the maple links like the little
jimmy deans
jimmy deans whatever yeah whatever so
good
breakfast sausages are off the floor
that's the best thing about thanksgiving
is my mom makes the sausage and then
there's a bunch extra
and i'll have it for breakfast like when
i come down all hung over yeah
[ __ ] make a sandwich and add it
tonight daddy oh that's it
those things are crispy too i like it
yeah so there you go so wait just one
birthday you remember
i don't remember i i remember that
birthday but i remember getting cakes i
don't remember
i don't remember anything now and now
you go all out for the kid now i assume
so we do a birthday party every year at
my house and i invite the last time it
was
last year it was only 20 people but
before covet it was 60 people
mm-hmm i i got a bouncy house i got a
zip line i saw the instagram stories
yeah i hired a [ __ ] clown
and presents were looking at potentially
well not
well it's it's i invite all my comic
people right like you know colin norton
gullman hamilton [ __ ]
gomez all those [ __ ] people come up
they're all standing in the corner
talking [ __ ] to the clown
like this guy's a [ __ ] hack he's been
doing the same bits as the 80s it kind
of does
i mean and then all of my kids friends
come and they're parents
so that does happen like all the comics
just cluster sure
and true check out that [ __ ] dork in
the shorts or whatever you know
yeah hold on that brings up something
i'm interested in yeah uh
if you can say this i would like to know
who's the best gift giver
out of your successful comedian friends
i know right now dante
dante nero dante nero drop on the kid
gary goldman is dante and gary really
but dante nero
picture colin look colin now colin did
give a great gift
he is a great gift gifter and he would
probably colin would be the one
but dante goes so overboard sure i could
see that
i mean he bought him this great guy
he bought him this i mean it's like a
it's like a big wheel
damn but it's uh like it it's automatic
like you could sit in it and [ __ ]
drive around the neighborhood at five
miles an hour
go go get the paper with it
you know what i mean yeah he he goes
nuts he bought him and then
and i was like dante's so great but then
dante had a kid i'm like [ __ ] now
now you're fine now you're out 200 plans
that brings out that brings this up if
you're going to a wedding say you were
going to
foley's wedding yeah what are you
dropping at a wedding
first of all i'm not going
[Laughter]
are you gonna make up an excuse like
guys oh no no i'm gonna go
i'm not coming i'm not coming no i i
don't go to weddings anymore
really i do not i think no i think it's
garbage
weddings are a scam weddings are a
[ __ ] fantasy
weddings is a waste of money in a while
you might as well just buy land in a
tiny home
and [ __ ] guys in a tiny home pyramid
trying to get you involved
or buy some money's in the licenses dude
buy a [ __ ] time ship put money in the
bank get stocks you're wasting
thousands of dollars of course on a day
to pretend
like you're royalty sure and that's [ __ ]
to me
i think you should take all that money
right
just have a part go get elope go on your
vacation yeah
and then have a little party after and
let everybody come and drop a check you
can have the money
i don't care you can have the money but
i'm not [ __ ] dropping
five bills on a [ __ ] day of just getting
a hotel
somewhere or something new [ __ ] to like
i'm your
i'm your minions like i'm your hey
but you had it you had a wedding did not
i wear lopes you did where'd you go yes
i went to maui which sucked
yeah what hawaii this guy sounds like a
good time really because i love aruba i
wanted to just go to aruba uh
she was like i'll do it but i want to i
want to elope but let's do it with maui
i'm like that's a
that's a [ __ ] 10 000 trip yeah
and and look god bless maui i love you
people
you i think you're my people he blessed
himself i don't know because i i
bless the people of maui they're big
people you see those people they think
bobby's a god
big guys big women yeah those [ __ ]
women
is that samoan or something uh samoan
and hawaiian there's people with some
moment descent
yeah yeah they were they were conquered
by captain cook back in the day
for nails he tricked him with nails who
captain cook
uh he's the guy who discovered hawaii
then they murdered him turn into [ __ ]
wikipedia
welcome back to bad history with bobby
kelley ah they got [ __ ] scammed over
there
shook a keychain distracted him stole
the whole island
so look it up you don't believe me look
at that
not now wait till i leave it
not now wait don't embarrass me but uh
you got more about oat milk
i [ __ ] would love some it was sweet
but yeah no so no weddings i get it
that's that's good weddings are a waste
i don't have [ __ ] money and a waste
of time and you don't like all those
people
and you're [ __ ] up their day nobody
wants to go
nobody truly wants to go everybody wakes
up on wedding and he goes [ __ ]
all right let's go put that stupid suit
on get the thing go to the thing go to
the church
you're gonna be crying you see him up
there being phonies
you know they were doing ass play the
night before and she's wearing white
right now get the [ __ ] out of here
and uh and then and then you're gonna go
to the stupid venue and you're gonna
wait for them to show up and then
there's an entrance
and they're doing photos and you're just
everybody's starving them by the time
you eat it's [ __ ]
then you're gonna do the stupid when i
no no no no i said go
[ __ ] yourself god bless you should he
get married at a bowling alley yeah well
check out the chicken dance
i mean they're still doing the chicken
things when was the last time you were
awake yeah no
[ __ ] every wedding i've ever been to
does the [ __ ] chicken dance
it's like a thing and even if you don't
know what's the track that is yeah
that's a chicken i mean they did we made
it rollers maybe a mock-up
at the rollerskates colin had a good
wedding yeah
i'll tell you why colin's wedding was
good he did everything in the same spot
that's one dude
recently did he get married recently it
was just back in the day it was a couple
years ago
i went to my first wedding that did that
they got married
in like the one side of the building and
then you walked 10 feet to the reception
hall and i was like
you can do this they had a bar at the
ceremony which was fantastic so what'd
you give colin can we ask that
says that was that the last wedding you
went to we we actually
um we hired an artist we commissioned an
artist to do a painting
[Laughter]
glasses on painting a rodney dangerfield
the orangutan well here's the thing
here's the problem with that i
this artist was i really like uh
and we commissioned to do this that's
classy that's very classical and it was
i don't know about you no it is you're
conditioning an artist that you like
dude what are you talking about he's got
money he's got money right she's on snl
you you cash him
money he's got it give me venmo now how
about that
that's like giving you chips
a couple of susie queues on a cop patio
yeah go ahead
geez thanks bob i don't know what to say
you got the family back i uh yeah we we
commissioned but here's the problem with
that
because it's art which is subjective
like stand up
you know you're not everybody it stinks
right wow no
no [ __ ] you i know you're trying to i
don't think you're happy with how it
came out
i loved it and now hold on when you say
commissioned okay
is this a formal process or did you find
some bozo that paints
paintings sorry i went down to flush
with washington square park
and i had a guy with a spin spinny art
thing and he spun
yes look at this it's a sunset he went
to sears and got fingerprinted
[Laughter]
it's colin driving in a little car
i went down to the jersey shore it's
just big head calling
no i commit it's an artist he did it he
was it's a i loved it it's a beautiful
piece
and my wife loved it we were very happy
with it we gave it to them
but then here's the thing with art is
that you know aft after you give
somebody a gift
you're waiting for that response you
give somebody money you just that's it
you're done
it's a transaction the transaction oh my
god we got situated we settled it's in
the main
mantle piece you're waiting to hear hey
bob
hey what's up listen man we're on i
can't believe you did fantastic
never came hmm wow so i had to go
you know what i mean and i was like you
just stole it back no i
had to call them up and be like listen
man uh hey did you
you liked the painting oh yeah oh that
wasn't good
then he goes no no no you knew he didn't
like it i go i go
uh you know jen yeah yeah we're gonna
hang it i go
well it's not they didn't like it and
then it was like
you want me to just take it back i can
take it back i'll keep it i'll put it up
in my house we love you too
that'd be hilarious just we have a wall
of art like original art in our house
from people
just caught them but uh biting us
knuckles
we we uh but then he finally called me
up late he goes let me tell you we
that really grew on us that's a lie
though you know that no
where do you put it where'd he put it
harley quinn is too funny
he's too funny there's nothing that he
would like
better than to not like it and have us
and be like yeah we think it stinks he
would love to do that he
it did grow on him so well it's like i i
tell you
i my my therapist uh
alan allen i went yeah okay great he
he says to me i was talking about art i
used to do art before comedy i wasn't i
went to art school i was gonna be an art
teacher
he goes you should do you should paint
again so i went and bought all this [ __ ]
i got my easel up my french view
i start painting in the living room i
take it over the whole lure my wife
[ __ ] hates it
i paint this painting and i my first
painting i give to him
to allen allen oh yeah i give it to him
because he's got all the art in this
office from from clients okay
so a year later we actually have an
argument i'm fighting with this [ __ ]
but i'm yelling at him and he's like you
did and i go yeah and i
[ __ ] go and i go [ __ ] you and where's
my
painting i want it up this guy's nuts i
want my painting up the next time i come
here
you pop all this [ __ ] out you [ __ ]
and the next time i came if you come out
of the bathroom
it's right in front of the [ __ ]
he put my painting up right there so if
you ever go there it's right there
it's uh yeah who's the painting
stuff colin quinn do you want to see it
yes i'll see if i can find it what's the
next question
wait did colin ever confirmed with you
that your painting was was put up
did you witness it in his home i don't
know should i call him and ask him no
no no call you sure yes no all right
all right put him on the spot what about
verzi's wedding didn't you go to
versie's wedding what's not
hundred dollars a person class a person
a person so you and your wife come to my
wedding you're giving me 400. i'm
guess who just got invited to foley's
wedding it's gonna be the four of us
if i'm coming to your wedding i'm giving
200 a pop yeah all right because i got
gotta pay for the meal
you gotta you gotta cover your plate i
gotta cover my plate but i wanna cover
the people working there too so i'm
gonna go
150 feet [ __ ] chicken or whatever the
[ __ ] you got
and i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do 50
bucks for the people that are working
there
why i don't go to weddings because i
hate dropping that much money
on some day that i don't even [ __ ]
want to be at sure i
hey i get it i i didn't invite you to
mine i went to a wedding
where they had such they had a four-hour
break in between the wedding and the
reception oh my god we had to go to
mcdonald's
you didn't have to i'm sure there was a
sound i was contractually obligated
to hit the mickey d's three miles i'm
sure there was a sweet greens or
something in the area yeah
even chipotle or something we had to go
to make do autos
um all right we got to get out here a
couple years let's run through a few
more
all right this is from connor hicks this
is a pretty good one how do you open a
disposable straw wrapping
is it to hold the straw in the fist and
bang on the bottom or do you do like the
classy rip and pull out the
i like to hop on from i'm an animal the
neanderthal
right you break the structure and then
teeth break the strokes break the straw
then you're [ __ ] if it's
nothing worse you break the straw you
gotta have good technique though you
gotta be soft
buddy you don't know though you know
what type of straw you're gonna make
[ __ ] mcdonald's can withstand them
listen you break that straw you crack
that [ __ ] straw
it's over you you're done and you're
drinking like this
that's how i prefer it though i drink
from a straw too quick i got good
suction i'm like a dyson
oh it's all [ __ ] gone if you have a
crack in that straw you're not sucking
anything
true that's what i'm saying you're
getting maybe halfway through the drink
you peel the top off like a [ __ ]
person
wow that's clay i don't do that oh but
can i say this
i peel the top off and then i tap it so
i do both actually
i peel and then tap oh i know what
you're saying yeah and then
i still go i'm 50 and i still go like
that i don't hate it i'm a big fan of
that i waited tables for so long that i
can just
i can just do the rip and then put
destroying with the with the little
piece of paper which he's gone and like
he's got he's grabbed us all his coffees
and he comes back
with that which is pretty it's a nice
touch thank you for that
that is a nice touch i do like that when
your buddy you i lick the straw
you're already kind of disgusted by him
when he hands you a sanitizer
look at my fingers yeah you know he's
licked his fingers oh dude
it's he skeeves me if you knew
my fingernails get real dirty and i know
what i noticed
you look like a coal miner for some
[ __ ] i know out of nowhere this is
his only job is to show up here twice a
week and
yeah every once in a while look down
like i don't know how i just took a
shower and scrubbed everything
i don't know where it's coming from i'll
tell you where you're boogers you're
[ __ ]
everywhere yeah dude stop touching [ __ ]
yeah this is the guy
[ __ ] touching my strolls
great question uh yeah fantastic
i think for the record though yeah
banging it is trash
because you are gonna snap it if you bat
if you peel it and tap i like a tap
i don't like straw if i'm at a
mcdonald's or a chipotle or something
i go no straw i take the little and i go
no straw that's just
that's just nuts that's [ __ ] you're
drinking the whole drink i like to live
on the wild
you you don't even let it you can't even
let it sit for a minute you you have to
drink the whole [ __ ] thing
why you're gonna put your water back on
it yeah no if i'm what do you mean if
i'm walking around
what type of balance do you have not to
spill a [ __ ] what in the door oh wait
in the car or where are you talking
yes at all
[Laughter]
immediately that's the same page you're
on no i'm saying if i'm sitting down in
the middle are you gonna hold your four
whoppers i don't understand
and all the toys from here uh no i would
take the yeah if i'm sitting and i take
it off i'm if i'm maneuvering yeah but
then the [ __ ] air gets in it like the
the mcdonald's [ __ ] air
no [ __ ] food i'm not worried about the
air [ __ ] okay snowden take it easy
i'm eating like 15 chicken beaks in my
nuggets i'm not worried about the air
i got let him do the snowden joke again
yeah
[Laughter]
hey you stepped on it i liked it
bobby's such a [ __ ] he's kind of like
you where you never know where you're
sitting like oh we're best friends and
then he [ __ ] pulls up
pulls the rug out for another year can
you get a straw in your eye
yeah it keeps you on your [ __ ] toes i
like it i'm having a good time they get
hit with a radio
yeah i feel like that guy that you're
[ __ ] beat up in the park
oh my god bobby's great
[Laughter]
all right let's see here let's let's run
through a couple of more um
this is from walter have you ever left
something outside to get i mean now that
you have a house in the burbs have you
ever
left something outside to get cleaned
off by the rain because you were too
lazy to do it yourself
um what the [ __ ] is that i don't know
like a lawn i don't know
i don't i mean i've left stuff outside
but not to do not just in purpose
wait a minute wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait who's cutting the grass by the
way you were
you got a guy out of your mind i do
everything in my house
like i build stuff i do the garden with
my wife i
i do a lot of stuff i'll you know i
clean the gutters i'll [ __ ] clean the
house but i don't do the milan
not the maintenance no i don't do that
[ __ ] number one the
artist no no the guy when we went in
there i was all prepared to get a lawn
mower and all that [ __ ] and uh the guy
doing it guy tano he's like
90 italian guy he [ __ ] waddles he's
been doing this place
for 30 years and i didn't want to take
the job away from yeah
so i just was like and he's he's he's
[ __ ]
murdered two of my lilac bushes he's
taken out [ __ ] treat like little
uh uh like some of our plants you know
he'll just weed wax [ __ ]
we had this grass that is like special
grass that we put in the front rock
garden
and one of his guys just come up with a
weed wagon
what are you doing he goes trimming the
grass i'm like that's not grass
but i can't fire him i can't fire him
because he's this old italian guy
and i just i i feel like he has to be in
my life so
i respect it i respect i don't hate it
you're crazy but i respect them
i love it um all right let's wrap up on
this one this is from emmett did you
ever take part in the st
patrick's day parade
actually in it on a float or walking
holding like one of those aoh banners or
something
some dirt bag i did yeah i did it was in
boston
uh me and alan the monkeys
owl and the monkeys they we were i i'm i
know who
who are they it was al time forget al's
last name
your comedy troupe al del beni dane cook
that's right
you and i think that's it maybe no j
hall j hall yeah uh we
we uh jay hooked it up you guys got
booed at the garden
we got a [ __ ] after like pearl jam or
something right right uh spin dock just
picked up
between spin doctors and fish they had a
[ __ ] bobby and the monkeys go out
they had us go up and do uh improv in
between those two they were like same
they were like a famous
regional really for a hot man after that
though
things went downhill just a bunch of
bunch of hippies on acid like are they
making all this up
oh no those hippies are violent i've
never had that many
[ __ ] flip-flops and lighters thrown
at my [ __ ] head
they were violent [ __ ] people man but
yes i we're in a float we were we were
in a convertible
car how do you do improv while moving
somebody give me a job
name an occupation on the windshield
wipers oh no i said i go
i literally said this i go get those
three things that you you hate besides
us
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh it was bad it was [ __ ] bad how'd
you get into the parade
well that was jay hall who uh knew
somebody in east boston
he got us in this [ __ ] parade i
imagine
all our troubles are over we're in the
parade
it was [ __ ] great though because i've
always i've always wanted to be in the
parade
sure stay parade talking in boston
well we weren't in these saint patties
this was the east boston little small
thing oh that's good oh my god you're in
an off-brand parade just in the back of
an el camino
who doesn't get the main stage at a
parade paddy says one t
i'm pretty sure the little league was
the behind us as the finale
but
[Laughter]
guys if we do well this year they said
we could play ball next year with them
in a big league all you got to do is
walk straight what's the [ __ ] problem
you're making a left and a right
we're never gonna get to the big time if
you're jesus get your act together we're
never gonna make it to basics
i believe it was 15 minutes a 20 minute
parade
yeah it was like up a street yeah
and then i listen we're to start on
second street go to third street
and then we're going to hit the bat all
right go
go pretty sure that was it you've seen
the italians in a way you beat him up
that's all you got to do no but it was
italian section east boston was all
excited so it was the italian version of
it
oh [ __ ] oh that's fantastic but i
remember this i remember eating lasagna
green spaghetti and meatballs nobody
nobody knew
who we were yeah no [ __ ] i remember just
little kids looking up going who's that
and the mother was like i don't know
yeah like we we the person that person
that did the parade
loved us but didn't take into account
that nobody
those are always the worst gigs ever the
worst yeah they're like oh i love you
i'm a big fan and then you're sitting
there and i was like who the [ __ ]
invited this guy nobody else knows you
exactly
those are the worst gigs when one person
thinks you're great the guy booking it's
like i know the best comedian
yeah and they bring you in it's just a
bunch of [ __ ] answers
he's dying laughing in the back you're
bombing everybody else oh man
i thought you were good i've gotten that
not too long ago to be honest
well i'm so rusty i was down in helium
with akash and somebody's like i thought
you were good
everybody else thought you sucked yeah
yeah that's worse that's that's worse
than you too
you're the best comic ever oh you too i
mean i think we talked about it on
hard on the patreon but uh just to show
the levels of comedy like like the
show's doing well so people were like
i loved afterwards like i loved the
[ __ ] podcast they're so cool like
they were like i was like coming out
like kippy i felt famous i'm like this
is great yeah and then i talked to this
i talked to this couple for 10 minutes i
was on top of the world and i walked
back into the showroom
and some girl goes uh can you get me a
pen and i'm like uh no i don't work here
and her husband's like
no he's one of the comedians she goes oh
i know i'm like she's like can you find
me a pen i'm like
oh god it's gonna be in your neck
and stab your [ __ ] jugular you
[ __ ]
loudmouth [ __ ]
i was like right back to i walked i
walked into the showroom feeling like a
million bucks
and then this chubby brother asking me
for a pic oh that's
[ __ ] [ __ ] they really just bring
it ah what a [ __ ] twist oh no i know
can you find me a pen find me she said
he gave me a [ __ ] to-do list [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right what an episode what a show
bobby thank you
so much so much thank you so much yes
thank you guys anything you want the
folks
to know you got coming up what uh yeah
with my dates robert kellylive.com you
go to
for all my comedy dates i'm back on the
road for march april which i'm very
excited about
and then of course patreon.com robert
kelly
i know you remember this patreon but uh
you know i'm over there too with a bunch
of [ __ ] so we're all doing
we're all trying to [ __ ] make it
happen and keep the [ __ ] going i'm glad
it's opening up
and i'm so happy for your success you
too because i've always liked you thank
you and i really love you
never wanted nothing really to do it yet
oh we know
i'm glad you found something thank you
i'm glad something clicked
thank you i mean right at the buzzer
didn't it
you have no idea oh gee it looks like a
celtics lakers game
three two you guys both woke up on the
floor did it work
it went in thank god foley's got a half
court career yeah
fellaini was about to kill himself in a
closet with twinkies
that pandemic was coming in like a
perfect storm
hey you better do something now boys if
you want to make it through
kippy was about to sell [ __ ] real
estate yeah so
i was i was looking to get my series 6.
he was going to get a [ __ ] uh
townhouse in bensalem pennsylvania
i went to school there in bensalem
pennsylvania next podcast
oh jesus holy [ __ ] ladies and gentlemen
the one the only mr robert kelly buddy
so much so much thank you
kippy what do you got just as always
please make sure you subscribe
on youtube itunes uh it helps us out we
appreciated patreon.com for bonus
content and the live show guys
um they're all socially distant yes
limited seating so get your [ __ ]
tickets
uh for coming to your town uh it'll be a
good time it'll be a little bit of stand
up a little bit of ayg with you guys
we'll be taking questions
it'll be a good time to get involved
it's going to be fun get those tickets
for riley and for zaney's
asap we love you we'll see you next week
peace hold on there cowboys and cowgirls
before you guys step on out of the
saloon here
i want to talk to you partners real
quick one more time
about that good old stereo app you got
kippy and uncle hank there thursday
nights nine o'clock
but i got a lot of other good things to
know about it yeah guys i like this
character baby it's juicing me up
uh guys if you're not familiar go check
it out we're there every week it is a
fun
time it's a good way for you to interact
with us and the show and the other
people you get to hear other people's
questions
uh we get a couple hundred people tuning
in every every time it's it's a lot of
fun
there's a lot of good shows on there so
check it out go to stereo.com
kevin ryan or slash h foley the link
will be in the description of the show
check it out we'll see you there yeehaw
peace